speaking at an election rally in the
city of nara
[Music]
this is the moment japan's former prime
minister shinzo abe is attacked
two gunshots
fired from behind they strike a bay in
the back
and doctors say the neck he collapses
his shirt covered in blood
chaos and confusion as security wrestles
the suspect to the ground
and shinzo abe airlifted to hospital
officials say he arrived with no vital
signs
he was not breathing his heart had
stopped
local media reports a male suspect in
his forties has been arrested
and that he told police he wanted to
kill the former pm
what appears to be a handmade gun was
reportedly used in the attack
as japan's longest serving prime
minister shinzo abe was a towering
figure on the international stage
at home he orchestrated an ambitious
plan to revive the country's ailing
economy
boris johnson called it incredibly sad
news
writing his global leadership through
uncharted times will be remembered by
many my thoughts are with his family
friends and the japanese people
the uk stands with you at this dark and
sad time
before abe's death was announced the u.s
described the former pm as an
outstanding leader and unwavering ally
our thoughts
our prayers are with him
as family with the people of japan
this is a very very
sad moment
as the shock sinks in there will be
questions
how could this happen
in one of the safest countries in the
world
where until now
political violence on this scale had
been almost unthinkable
nicole johnston
sky news